i was looking at your new video miley
and dua lipa are performing together on
the video
[Music]
[Applause]
i feel like you guys had sex during that
shoot we did not have sex dua lipa
constantly reminds me she gives me the
in your dreams
she has a boyfriend i'm free and can do
whatever the [ __ ] i want which
feels great for the first time in years
and years so i could have gone there but
miley is dual leap is somebody who you
would desire sexually
she's super [ __ ] hot but see that
isn't it for me that's not what
turns me on what turns you on everyone
wants to know
i need someone that's really can laugh
because
talking about some of this anxiety and
fear
i tend to be one of the people that try
to laugh through it if you don't laugh
you'll cry
like it can kind of take over so i need
someone
that kind of keeps life funny for me
and has a really interesting perspective
and but what about the what about the
sexual aspect of dua lipa i mean
the physicality of her yeah she's hot as
[ __ ] but that's just what we're talking
i would if it was an opportunity that
presented itself there's a lot of things
that i haven't really wanted
and then when when it comes to be in
front of me
there i go do you think because you live
in hollywood and because you're so super
successful
do you think you need someone in your
life who maybe isn't in the business
i'm thinking about you is that what did
in the marriage
no um what did in the marriage is
we were together since i was 16 our
house burned down
we had been like engaged i never i don't
know if we really ever thought
we were actually going to get married
but when we lost our house in malibu
which if you listen to my voice
pre and post fire they're very different
so that trauma really affected my voice
um i had so much and it was all gone
every song i had ever written was in
that house every photograph of me that
my parents had given to me
all my scripts like i lost everything
and so in trying to put that back
together
instead of going oh nature kind of did
something i couldn't do for myself it
forced me to let go
i ran towards the fire and me being an
intense person
and not wanting to sit with it and not
wanting to go you know
what could be purposeful about this i
just clung to what i had left of that
house which was me and him
and i really do and did love him very
very very much and still do always well
you